the cross I just want to show you around
where we are a little bit these robots
are just setting up for a bit of a
synchronized dance that they've been
doing every so often they're actually
designed to be sort of in-home helpers
there's a station over there where
they're making coffee there's one sort
of behind us where they're playing
basketball the ideas that they could be
sort of living aids for the disabled and
whatnot and there is all sorts of fun
things here for the crowds there are
mechanical arms that are reading your
horoscopes there's a basketball court
that can analyze your style and suggest
Improvement techniques so it's a very
very clever but over and above the fun
things there's some very serious things
here as well major Innovations for
industry Logistics mining ports all
sorts of things military iterations as
well and of course the big question here
is how is China doing in the AI race how
is it doing in particular in comparison
to its key competitor America because
the AI is a massively important new
front if you like in that sort of
competitive relationship between the two
and the answer to that Anna is sort of
relatively complex in order to have good
AI you need three things you need a lot
of data China has a relative amount of
very very good data in some areas less
than others you need very skilled people
they certainly have that but you also
need very very good software and
hardware and that is the section on
which genre's been a little bit hampered
because of a major U.S chips act that
came in last year so the US essentially
banned the export of its highest quality
technology to China to try and
essentially hamper the development of
this industry and China has retaliated
and there's a suggestion the U.S could
up those regulations so that kind of
battle is very hot and absolutely
playing out but look China has a lot of
strength too not least it's people power
huge population to do some of the more
uh sort of early sort of stage less
technically advanced work that needs to
be done to teach the computers uh what
to do this is absolutely an exciting
place to be at the moment and China
absolutely a very key player in this
industry